[Music]
on today's show we talk about how to
love somebody with trauma in their past
we talk about how to love your sisters
and your mom
and your dad when you're dealing with
family illness we talked to a guy whose
marriage is
he's got a kid on the way and he's got
some hard decisions to make stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody this is
john with the dr john daloni show
hope everything in your life is going
all right
it's probably not but it's a good way to
start from there
right what is that
it's probably not everything's probably
not going great i'm not trying to be
ugly james james just started laughing
at me like oh wow what a
way to lift everybody's spirits idiots i
loved it i loved it
you didn't i saw kelly just go
wow so good i listen i hope everything's
going good and it's probably not
there's probably something going on
there's probably some economic challenge
or personal challenge or family
boundary challenge it's like you might
as well come on and be like hey this is
the john doloni show your life probably
sucks
it probably does but that's all right
that's all right
because we're all having lives like that
together
but um whatever your life might be
wonderful and if it's wonderful good i'm
glad it is
and i'm rooting for you i'm cheering for
no way to go
but someday soon just kidding i'm glad
it's going awesome hey if you want to be
on the show we talk about mental health
relationships
good news right optimism and joy and
positivity i have some good news and
positivity i'd like to hear it speaking
of your gibson shirt
i played our mutual friend cody's gibson
sg
and i'm smitten with it and so i'm
gonna get it i mean i can't afford them
because they're so expensive but
here we go with the old we don't make
enough money thing but hey
listen number one i accept your apology
i realize what that was ah no it wasn't
a problem and i
accept your concession and i i
was so for the listener james and i are
in a new band together we're incredible
um i don't really know how to say that
humbly but uh
we're incredible the chances of us still
be being in this show
next year is low to quite low because
we'll have a pretty incredible record
deal
and um but i do love looking across the
room
at james ripping on that gibson sg
and your little fender telecaster is
just tucked nicely in its case
hey you you had nice things to say about
my telecaster your telecaster was nice
i actually thought this morning um it'd
be cool if one of our shows
you played at gibson i played that and
then i thought i just can't do that but
your telecaster is really nice what i'm
saying is i think we've come to a mutual
understanding
about gibson and fenders i feel like i'm
at like some big peace conference
listening to this this is like a love
fest i feel like we're at one side of
the peace conference
where somebody has conceded on their
side but the other person's like i don't
even need to concede because i was right
all along
but i am good all right that's enough
for you
hey the cool part about uh james is that
he also edits this show
see he edits the show and he just mutes
it
and he actually can cut and paste it
towards like i
love fender and he'll just cut and paste
it to say whatever he wants
i don't have to i see what you did there
hey so if you want to be on the show
call give me a call 1-844-693-3291
uh you leave a message let me know
what's going on in your in your heart
and your mind and in your life
and how we can help and then kelly will
call you and we'll put you on the show
or you can go to johndaloni.com
ask ask all right let's get right to the
phones what's up cam in chicago hey kim
what's going on
hi dr john um thank you so much for
taking my call and i just will say that
i am blessed and my life is pretty
wonderful
it is awesome told you james just
kidding
hey thank you thank you for putting me
in my place i know that everyone's man
people are doing well right now
it's awesome so what's up how can i help
so my fiance and i are getting married
in october
okay and i'm calling because he
has had a very traumatic life um
and he's doing really well now and we're
really happy um
but i know that he never addressed any
of his traumas in counseling or anything
like that
so i'm kind of worried that his dramas
might manifest in some way in our
marriage
um is that something i should worry
about if no
how can i stop worrying and if yes how
can i help him
awesome question hey dude thanks for
loving that guy that's so good man when
y'all getting married
october 30th oh man so it's coming up
sooner rather than later
very cool okay so what kind of trauma
um everything under the sky so
i've heard you talk about the the ace
yeah that's right and i i looked at it
and i had him look at it with me and
i knew before showing it to him that he
was going to be high on it
because he's told me a lot of things but
what was his score
he's a 9 out of 10.
so everything under the sun literally
yeah
yeah wow and he's an amazing guy huh
oh my gosh yes he's he's he's incredible
so what would what would if you were
telling a story about him
what would you attribute that connection
between a nine out of ten so for those
who don't know the aces score the
adverse childhood experiences scale
um i think it was developed by nadine
brick harris uh
just a brilliant doctor i think she's
the attorney general now in california
i'm not attorney general i'm sorry the
chief medical officer of california just
an extraordinary
um practitioner researcher
what an incredible heart she she wrote
an awesome book called the deepest well
i recommend
everybody to read that book um but she
came up with the
i think her and her team came up with
the adverse childhood experience of
skill it's a 10
question scale and it's simple
like were you in a house of divorce did
anybody in your home go to jail were you
ever abused
et cetera and man if you have a nine out
of ten
the predictive nature that you are going
to have some major challenges everything
from cancers to strokes to heart disease
to
um psychiatric issues etc is
statistically
through the roof right and then now
you're calling me telling me you're
gonna marry this guy and he's
wonderful so if you are telling the
story how would you attribute that what
would you attribute
his wonderful character and nature to
um well he always says that
he always says that him and his siblings
had a way of
looking at the adults in their lives and
like taking it as an anti-example
um so that was that's
sort of what he says i
i'm not really sure i mean he met
the lord like last year and and got
baptized
um so he has a spiritual foundation huge
yeah
yeah before that he didn't at all like
he didn't even believe in god
um but um
so that's i've noticed like a really big
change in him since then
okay so that's awesome how old are you
guys
um he's 29 and i'm 27. okay
wow that was 30. wow wow so
here's a couple of things so if if i'm
if i
love somebody who's got a 9 out of 10
but it's someone who i'm married to one
of my best friends
i would look at that as highly
predictive
um but not prescriptive
and meaning not predetermined right
so there is a the recipe all the
ingredients are on the table for some
challenges downstream okay um
and it's something that i would highly
if i love this person
and i would highly recommend that um
that you create a life that would be
supportive and preventative
um sometimes trauma pops up in weird
ways like after your first kid
or after you get fired for the first
time or
there's a big catastrophic event
whatever that looks like
and sometimes people are just resilient
and strong and powerful and they've got
great people in their lives
and they've got a good spiritual
connection and they really take care of
their bodies and they sleep well
and so those of us who don't have a 9
out of 10 on the scale what we end up
doing
is we flinch every time they're in our
presence
and 9 out of 10 is that's a lot
most of us um have somebody that we love
whose parents were divorced or who may
have experienced abuse or maybe i had um
were sexually assaulted in college or
were in a bad car wreck
and what we do is we we anticipate in
that person's life
and almost create a self-fulfilling
prophecy where we
touch like we walk around with velvet
gloves we don't want to ever disturb
and so we keep secrets or we don't want
to bother them so we hold on to stuff
or we're really struggling but we don't
want to burn them because they've had a
hard life and whatever and so we hold on
to this stuff
they sense that gap and then their
alarms kick back up the old alarms that
kept them alive
does that make sense and so what you
don't want to do is to create a
self-fulfilling prophecy where you
spend your life looking at this person
that you love through a magnifying glass
looking for evidence of trauma from
childhood
emerging thereby creating a relatively
tense home or you keep secrets from each
other you don't tell them everything you
don't lean into it
you don't demand that he be a great
partner and a great husband and somebody
who shows up and somebody who works hard
somebody doesn't get fired
all these things um
because the past becomes this excuse and
i loved the
the phrase your past is a context it's
not an excuse
right it gives you some idea as to why
you may have an over-inflamed body you
may not
um default to good sleep you may
withdraw when
something gets heavy you may have
impulses towards anger or frustration or
addiction
but that doesn't give you an excuse to
then go down those paths does that make
sense
yeah so here's what's gonna be really
important for you guys
number one you gotta be really clear
with one another real clear
super honest and i would recommend i
don't know how you can get more honest i
would recommend
you guys having a default setting of
honesty
and connection now have you all gone
through any sort of premarital
counseling um we have met
with our priest like a couple of times
but i was planning on signing us up for
like
actual yes counseling with a counselor
so
think of it as um this you've got a
family history of heart disease and
obesity
and what you're going to do at an early
age you're going to graduate college and
you're going to be
more attentive probably than most to not
eating foods out of packages
to eating healthy whole foods you're
going to be um
intentional about moving your body and
exercising right so because you know
you've got this stuff
in you got the ingredients in the fridge
right and you don't ever want to just
start making it
same thing here so you can set up
preventative
counseling and what it is is just
learning tools he doesn't have a model
of what a healthy marriage looks like
and
you might not even either even though
you may not have a 10 or a 9 on the aces
score you may not have a good picture of
it either
so what you're going to do is you're
going to go learn new tools it's like
you're all taking a karate class where
you're going to learn to be ninjas
this is going to be learning how to be
merry right
and it's not because you're broken not
because you're dysfunctional you're just
learning new tools
and then you're going to really
default to creating a life early on
where
sleep is important friends are important
exercise is important gratitude journals
where you all tell each other what
you're grateful for
um really being in tension with your
spiritual communities right
and then you you
not trying to protect him from
your heart your thoughts your needs your
fears your concerns does that make sense
yeah absolutely have you found yourself
doing that in your relationship
um i i don't know if i
i've been trying to protect him but i
would say that
i sometimes do like think like
oh is this a manifestation of his trauma
like
projecting that onto him kind of
um do you see how that becomes a
self-fulfilling loop
yeah yeah absolutely where you project
it and then he thinks uh no it's not and
now there's a gap
and then he goes back to some old habits
to try to solve that gap
to which then you go there's the trauma
and then the loop just gets bigger and
starts spinning faster and faster
right and so it's you trusting when you
ask him are you doing okay and he goes
i'm doing awesome that you go great
and you don't start reading into that
right or if you
he says i'm doing awesome and then you
can then say you haven't come to bed the
last three nights and you've been
sleeping on the couch and you're playing
a lot of video games
and since we have been to counseling and
we know that withdrawal is one of the
things that sends you down a tough path
you're starting i feel you starting to
withdraw from me right and that he can
not respond in anger you leave me alone
but he says you're right i'm withdrawing
and then y'all can be right in the
middle of it does that make sense
yeah that way there's no projection
there's you being honest there's he
being honest and you all are just in it
and moving on
yeah that makes sense and to his credit
like
i should have said this earlier but he
really has done like a lot of work on
himself like
trying to cultivate a lot of like
awareness of what he does
and um you know sort of his
his toxic thought patterns wow
and since this calls about you really i
know you're calling about him but really
calls about you
um yeah he sounds like he you can't have
a 9 out of 10 a score and just
dust your hands and shake it off and be
like hey cool i'm doing great
right everything so you he clearly has
put in a lot of work
which is to his credit um don't
don't superimpose your fears on him
be honest with him put your fears out on
the table and say hey i would get
nervous about this stuff
i want to know what some of your toxic
thought patterns are and some of your
default settings are so that
if i see them i'd love to be able to put
them on the table and say hey this is
making me nervous or making me scared
it's when you feel nervous and scared
and you decide oh i can't bring this up
that's the recipe for disaster or you
bring it up and he says
no it's not then that's a recipe for
disaster right
it doesn't sound like that's the
trajectory y'all are on i want you to
have peace going into this
and you all do the work up front when
everybody's healthy everybody's doing
good it's like going to the gym when you
feel great not waiting until you have
the flu to start a workout program but
what a great heart i'm so excited for
you guys congratulations on getting
married
after your wedding shoot me a note that
just says hey we got married
all is awesome here in chicago and cam
we will be rooting for you guys
and for everybody listening two big
important takeaways
if you've got divorce in your life if
you've got
i'm filling in the blank here um family
history of addiction of heart disease of
whatever of mental health challenges
and you're doing okay you're doing well
set up a life while you're doing well
that will buffer for when the hard
seasons come right
it's like building your house on a good
strong firm foundation
so that when the hurricanes come and
they will come
it doesn't blow over right you've got a
strong foundation for when some of these
things
come back right ah good for you guys uh
all right let's go to
jared in iowa oh oh i just said two
things that was one
the second thing is don't project don't
project your fears onto your partner
it it'll melt them it'll melt them all
right let's go to jared in
iowa city jay rid what's up dude
hey hey good morning doc good hey i
almost made a
subway joke and then i realized it's not
funny anymore
so good for you jared
all right how old are you man uh 36.
did you get that growing up subway jokes
uh yeah yeah maybe the last few years or
so
if you'd been my friend i would have
been pretty relentless with them um but
i'm glad we're meeting now on the other
end of
jared's not that funny anymore all right
so what's up dude how can i help
uh yeah well i've got uh
been married for six years now
and basically i don't like it
i kind of hate being married um
it's it's just been a terrible marriage
the whole time
um we've never really gotten along it's
never been good
we've found out throughout the marriage
that you know we both kind of thought we
made a mistake right after getting
married
fast forward to now we're expecting our
first child
and uh kind of
kind of concerned that uh as to how it's
gonna
how this is gonna affect the child and
maybe get some
from your advice on
maybe how to uh better the marriage
and and or not let it affect our child
man you said a lot there um
congrats on having a kid and congrats on
recognizing that the way y'all are doing
stuff is
gonna melt that kid right yeah so when
you say
you don't like it it's never been good
when anyone says the word never i would
usually roll my eyes so
help me what never means it's never been
good what does that mean
i don't like it yeah basically uh
um you know we got married on a saturday
and and
sunday we both thought we'd made a
mistake and uh you know monday
we thought maybe we should have gotten
an annulment kind of a thing
yeah but that was six years ago dude
you're six years past right
right and it's it it just we don't get
along we uh
you know home is not it's not a place
where uh
uh where we want to be together anyway
you know i mean
why do y'all choose to do that
yeah it's a good question i guess from
my perspective
i think we should be you know living
large we're both doing well
professionally
you know but for six years y'all have
decided to be miserable
why have you chosen that
yeah i don't know it's uh it's been
tough so i'm asking you like why are you
choosing that
i um i try i actually try to wake up
every day you know
as a new day um you know with an
attitude of uh
you know hopefully hopefully it'll be a
better day and you know trying to try
and take steps
with her to uh uh you know
keep her happy i guess so this is all
her this is all her fault
no i wouldn't blame it on her that's not
that's not
uh so answer my answer my question
brother why
have you you got married on a saturday
you woke up on sunday and thought
whoops and then monday y'all talked
about hey we
think this is a script how'd y'all how
long did y'all date before that
um dated about a year and a half and
then we're engaged for about a year and
a
half
yeah here's the thing it wasn't a
mistake
it wasn't y'all may have woke up on
sunday scared to death
you may have woke up on monday terrified
found yourself like on a
on a roofing job with no tools right
y'all are in the middle of something you
know what you're doing
you didn't make a mistake y'all made it
a choice after three years together
y'all thought through this very very
well and now for the last six years so
you've got a decade in with this person
six years you have this well we
shouldn't have well we shouldn't have
and i'm sitting here listening to you
thinking yeah i bet you did
and so then what and so it sounds like
for six years you
you guys have actively chosen to
not cultivate desire to not just turn
all the lights on and say what are we
doing let's
get mad in love with each other it's
just been like oh he's trying to keep
her happy and today's gonna probably be
a good day
like and so i'm asking you you're you're
a good professional
right you said you're successful as a
professional
sure yeah you're not dumb right are you
dumb
um no yeah you're not dumb are you fun
to be around your friends like you
yeah like do you like music or sports or
things
yeah we have a good time generally so
why when it comes to your wife have you
chosen for a decade to be less than
joyful
not her why have you chosen that
yeah i i guess i don't
i don't think that i've chosen that as
uh actually
i tried to try to uh make the best of
things and
and uh yeah i know do you hear that
language it's like
yeah i'm not gonna have knee surgery i'm
not going to do physical therapy i'm
just going to try to limp the best i can
but you have actively chosen to not do
things to make this thing better
so let me ask you the other side why
haven't you just moved out dude why
don't you just leave
this is your one precious life
you got one and you've given a decade to
well i just probably shouldn't
like why why don't you just move out
well right and you know we've had uh
conversations about divorce i know
listen
i don't care about your conversations
why haven't you done it
um yeah i guess i i value i value the
marriage vows okay so if you made him
so you that you value the vowels you
value the the commitment
awesome
but you don't value the human on the
other end of that commitment
and you don't value the guy who made
that commitment
you see what i'm saying kind of
if you valued you you would say
dude i want to be madly in love with you
you would say dude we are going to have
a marriage of reckless
but crazy town sex a lot
we're gonna laugh like crazy we're both
gonna do whatever we wanna like we're
gonna have friends we're gonna have
hospital we have people over
we're gonna choose that life we're gonna
dance in the living room
we're going to go out with separate i
mean we're going to like i'm going with
my buddies you're going to hang out with
your friends we're going to go do other
things right
and it's like well we made this vow so
i just resigned to can i ask you a
personal well we're asking personal
questions we're already in it
you're not attracted to her are you
oh yeah yeah she's beautiful
are you sure yes
is she attracted to you
know does she think you're dumb
i don't think so
do you hear the question the answers to
the questions
like it's y'all are in this weird
stalemate why why do you think you
made a mistake
like for six years you've been living
with this idea that we just
we just made us we screwed up well it's
it's
um you know prior prior to the marriage
you know as far as dating and
and at the time of dating and engagement
you know she
we you know our relationship was one way
and and
um then after we got married you know
it it's like a uh switch flipped
um and now it's the other way what's the
switch
um you know again again we've talked
about it a little bit
uh i don't care what you talked about
talking with me what's the switch that
flipped she said
she she told me that that um that uh
when i were married so
um she doesn't have to be nice to me
anymore
[Music]
well played well
so she said i got married and now i
don't be nice to you i'm gonna be mean
and it affect your intimate life
probably
absolutely okay so now it's like i
gotcha so
why if you were writing a story about
your wife why would you
think that she is choosing to be
miserable because just being not kind
choosing to not have great sex with the
person you're married to choosing to not
do things with somebody
and walk around like oh well i guess
we're just like that's a
choice to be miserable why is she
choosing that
i don't know i wish i knew you have
known this woman for a decade
you've clearly had sex once because you
got a kid coming like you know her
why is she choosing misery over joy
i i don't know that's that's probably
the
brunt of the issue okay so here's here's
the thing have you ever seen talk to
anybody have you ever talked to
the council or anybody like that oh we
did the pre-marital counseling uh but
not nothing uh while we've been married
yeah that worked that worked out great
huh
right yeah just a bang-up job that one
was all right so here's the deal yeah
tonight you're going to go home and um
when she gets home and i want you to
turn
all the electronics off everybody's
phone off i want you to turn everything
off
and i want you to look at your wife and
say we didn't make a mistake
we've been lying to ourselves and
talking crap for a decade now for six
years plus the three we were married
we didn't screw up we got married and
for whatever reason
not don't project this onto her project
this unto yourself
say the words i have been choosing to be
miserable
less than happy just ho humming through
life
instead of choosing to learn
desire to practice
desire i have chosen to go
and i've got one precious life and i
chose to spend it with you
and i value you and i value me and i
want to
completely from the floor before this
baby gets here
because here's the thing your baby will
absorb all his tension
all this mayhem all this chaos
and if you think it's bananas now wait
till you got a
one month old that cries all night and
then craps everywhere
right all i have to say is you're in it
now dude
and you've got one of two choices you
can run like a loser
with a leave a pregnant woman alone
and you're not gonna do that the only
other choice you have
that's not true you got two other
choices one choice number two is just
continue living a miserable
milk toast life and congratulations dude
you're gonna wake up and be 55 you're
gonna be overweight your knees are gonna
hurt your back's gonna hurt you're gonna
have headaches she's not gonna like
you're not gonna like her you're gonna
look at too much porn
and then you're gonna be that guy or you
can put a stick in the ground and say
today
i am going to do whatever i have to do
whatever i have to do
to not save this marriage not me to love
you to learn to desire you and that
means you're gonna have to make a lot of
changes in your life
and i want you to invite her in this
journey and probably if she's been
sharing a bed with a dude who's like man
we really screwed up should we just get
divorced
[Music]
she's gonna go okay cool whatever dude
you're gonna have to just start making
some of these changes on your own
you're gonna have to go all in on you
because you can't change her
you can't but you can tell her i will
not give up on you and i'm gonna start
this thing from the floor up
and and here hear me dude why
why do anything other than that
to everyone listening if you're if
you've committed your life to somebody
why do anything other
than try your just damnedest to be
crazy in love why would you do anything
other than that it's insanity
it's choosing misery it's choosing lame
it's choosing
yeah oh my gosh
fight for it man you go see somebody
about yeah low-level dysthymia you go
see somebody about
i don't know man like i don't even trust
myself you go see somebody about
i'm about to be a dad and i don't even
know what i'm doing i'm scared about it
i think you all are both
scared my guess is you both got stuff
you both got models of marriages that
aren't great
so you don't have a good picture of what
it looks like you thought it was gonna
feel like this
[ __ ] that was gonna feel like that and
here's the thing man i promise you if i
was talking
to her she'd be telling me a story about
you and so your story is about her
just tonight enough
tonight enough enough enough and dude
you're on a multi-year journey that just
doesn't get
fixed next week
[Music]
and it's going to involve everything
from movement to your body to sleep to
exercise to changing how you eat to you
getting some friends to you go seeing
counselor
to you guys deciding
we're going to figure out how to love
each other recklessly we're going to
practice desire
god almighty don't choose misery people
don't
don't don't
all right we'll be right back dr john
delaney
[Music]
hey what's up i want to take a quick
break to talk about the most important
question i'm asked almost every day
how do i find a counselor if you can't
find a counselor in your area
or you can't afford one i've got a
solution for you
i've partnered with a better help for
customized
online therapy video chat text chat
phone counseling it's a licensed
therapist whenever
and wherever you need them go to
betterhelp.com
slash deloney for 10 off your first
month
it's cheaper and it's available all the
time
this is for you your family and for
everyone else that's coming your way
take care of your mental health go to
betterhelp.comtoday
all right let's take one more call let's
go to megan in milwaukee
what's up megan how are you doing i'm
pretty good thanks how are you
we are rocking and rolling rock and roll
so pretty good so what does that mean
tell me what's going on
so my question for you today is how do i
set boundaries with my family
um after my dad's cancer diagnosis being
the only
medical professional in my immediate
family
oh no what a great question and what a
miserable place
so tell me about your dad man
so my dad was such a hard worker i mean
he was the type of guy that would
help anyone out no matter what day what
time he would always be there so he was
a guy who worked
like six seven days a week never
complained always you know how can i
help someone
and so this past fall um started getting
sick which
he is typically never sick so after a
couple of weeks of in and out of the
doctors
um we found out that he had stage four
renal cell carcinoma
oh god so what's the prognosis is there
a timeline they've given y'all
so they haven't really given us a great
timeline by any means but
like five-year survival rates aren't
good for stage four
yeah yeah so i mean within a couple
weeks of that diagnosis we found
out that um he had a brain tumor so it's
it's kind of been one thing after
another he was hospitalized for a couple
months
and obviously navigating this in a
pandemic has been
a nightmare that's kind of the extra
layer exactly yeah
and so what what's what's your
profession you're a medical professional
you a doctor a nurse practitioner what
do
you
what do you do i'm a nurse practitioner
okay
yeah yeah dude so
here's the it's this is a a simple fix
and it will feel hard um
and if anybody well
it's as simple as this do you have
brothers and sisters who's contacting
you everybody mom everybody
so it's my brother really isn't in the
picture right now he's had his mental
health issues over the years
um so it's really my sister and my mom
okay and pretty much
you know the calls initially were what
does this mean
how do i navigate health care right kind
of the logistical questions
and now the questions i'm getting are
more i mean for my sister she's called
me
numerous times saying well when is he
going to die is he going to make it till
his birthday
like some of those questions which of
course i don't have answers to
right um and my mom kind of goes back
and forth between
you know i just hear fear and you know
being overwhelmed
constantly in her voice um and
so she at times is saying well he's
declining i think he's gonna die soon
and then other times it's well no one's
giving us a straight answer
and you guys as healthcare professionals
and so sometimes they get looped into
the u
of healthcare yeah so you're trying
you're trying to
offer support while offering information
but yet you know
especially during the pandemic like i'm
not at
these office visits i've gone to i think
one of his visits
i'm around and like i work next door to
the facility where he
receives his care so like i'm physically
nearby
but the i think the questions that they
have for me most of the time i don't
have answers to or the answers i have
are not
you know i think i think for both of my
parents they're
thinking that there's light at the end
of this that oh well cancer is not going
to be around his entire
life gotcha and i'm seeing the other
aspect where it's like
he may not be around in the next five
years that's right and so trying to have
some of those conversations
while also not wanting to overwhelm my
mom and also not having the full the
full story because
i'm not at all the appointments yeah
so it's really common
for people who do this for a living what
you do
to be faced with it personally and have
it be unmooring
because you may have
talked to a thousand
struggling moms or struggling wives who
are
looking down the barrel of becoming a
widow right
or you may have met with thousands of
people who get a prognosis that is not
good or whatever that happens to be
and then all of a sudden it's dad
and all your academic training and all
of your experience goes out the window
because that's
dad right and
then everybody handles it differently
just you describing
your mom was a i mean that's just
ping-ponging through
elizabeth kubler-ross's stages right
like i'm denying this this isn't real
too oh my gosh she's gonna die today to
you people i'm angry right it's just
that's just that she's in a grieving
state and she will be for the next 18 24
months until this thing
um probably takes his life and so
i think at the end of the day the best
thing to do is to sit down with your mom
and sister and be as honest with them as
you just were with me
and let them know hey i am a nurse
practitioner
one of the things i agree to do to
people who i love is i will interpret
and so i'll be an interpreter um if
somebody calls and says hey my kid just
got diagnosed with this or i just got
this meds what does this mean
i will say this is what that means to me
not gonna give you counseling care for
your kid i can't be that person for you
i'm gonna be your friend
right i can't be my wife's therapist i
can't
won't be if she says hey i got this
homework assignment what does this mean
then i might tell her i might give that
homework assignment to a client if
x y z but i'm not ever going to
be her cow i can't right and so i think
it's sitting down and letting your
mom and your sister know
hey i'm grieving this with y'all and i'm
not in these appointments i don't know
and this is my dad and so i'm not going
to be the nurse here
if you're comfortable with interpreting
right if they can put you on
speakerphone when a doctor
um calls is meeting with them or you can
step away and come over to a meeting
just to interpret great but you don't
need to be the person telling your mom
that
dad's got 16 months that doesn't need to
be your job you need to be
the daughter who hugs her mom when your
dad gets a bad
prognosis right does that make sense
yeah it does you know it's one of those
things that i immediately feel like when
i'm getting a call from
my mom or my sister that i'm taking off
the
the sister or daughter hat and
immediately putting the medical hat on
because i know they're a math
so and so you know you're trying to be
like the strong person
and hey not your job on the other hand
right
you know i'm grieving this with with
friends and colleagues like i
don't feel like i can even grieve this
with my own family
so here a great great gift you can give
your mom and your sister
is what you just said this is my daddy
not one of my patients
and i'm not i don't work in oncology i
don't you might work in oncology but
it doesn't sound like you're a cancer
doctor
and um
i don't know all i know is that my
daddy's really sick it doesn't look
great and i need my sister and my mom
and if we get some news some kind of
medical jargon i'm happy
to interpret um but i just need my
sister and my mom right now
and so please don't ask any more medical
questions anymore i don't know i just
don't know these things but i know that
i need you guys
and i think that conversation among
three women who love each other dearly
and three women who are hurting in
unique and different ways
will be really powerful and important
and for whatever it's worth meg and i'm
so so sorry that your dad
is sick so so sorry
oh thank you so much he's a good guy huh
yeah i mean he he's a guy that he
doesn't say much but you know
he truly it's you know he gives the
shirt off his back he sounds like a
six to seven day a week working
midwestern male right
yeah and so i mean for him like
obviously
obviously the cancer diagnosis in and of
itself i worry about
but you know he went from being an
independent guy to
a feeding tube and a walker and so i
mean
everything's been stripped from him and
the way you just described that is
a very clinical way and that's how
you're trained
to work through these situations i want
you to allow yourself whether it's with
your husband
hopefully it's with your sister and your
mom to
allow yourself to just sit in the
devastation of this powerful strong man
who we
who carried us through life now on a
feeding tube
right there's a part of that that has to
be witnessed you've got to go through
that process
holding this at arm's length like you do
with your patience is a recipe for this
thing
hanging on to you for the rest of your
life and so don't rob yourself of the
grieving process
get right smack in the middle of it and
it will make you an empathetic caretaker
moving forward it'll make you a great
sister
but most importantly you get to be a
celebrating daughter
of a guy who carried the family through
and
is slowly slowly leaving us man
i am grateful grateful for your call and
we'll be thinking about you guys i'll be
praying about you guys
and um
i think it's gonna be a powerful
conversation for you i really do
and
cancer sucks i hate it
hate it hate it hate it hate it
by the way tell your dad that you love
him
make sure you tell him that a lot not as
nurse megan but his daughter begging
make sure your dad knows that write him
a letter so he can read it
tell him what a great guy he was what a
great example he was what a powerful
example he was all those things
let him know oh man all right so as we
wrap up today's show let's see here man
let's get some good
lyrics to wrap up today's show
oh man hey james do you ever listen to
the the
2011 the blink 182 record the
neighborhoods
no man okay it's got one of the
my favorite guitar riffs of all time
even through all the metal and punk it's
a
slippery good really
just remarkable guitar riff one of my
favorite songs ever it's off the 2011
neighborhoods record it's a blink 22
song it's a very different blink song
it's called up all night and it goes
like this everyone wants to call
it all around our life with a better
name everyone
falls and spins and gets up again with a
friend who does the same and everyone
lies and cheats their wants and needs
and still believes their heart
and everyone gets the chills the kind
that kills when the pain begins to
start did i get this straight do you
want me here as i struggle through each
and every year and all these demons they
keep me up
all night they keep me up all
night hey put the bricks down everybody
man
don't let those demons keep you up
anymore right here dr john de la show